> DR. FAUCI WILL STEP DOWN AS
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CHIEF MEDICAL
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES WHICH HE
LED FOR 38 YEARS THIS DECEMBER.
HE JOINED THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH BACK IN
1968, WHEN LYNDON B. JOHNSON WAS
PRESIDENT, BECAME THE DIRECTOR
OF ITS INFECTIOUS DISEASE BRANCH
IN 1984 AS THE AIDS EPIDEMIC
GRIPPED AMERICA AND HE'S ADVISED
EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE REAGAN,
SEVEN IN TOTAL.
JOINING US NOW IS DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI.
DR. FAUCI, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MAKING THIS YOUR FIRST INTERVIEW
ON CNN SINCE ANNOUNCING YOUR
DEPARTURE YESTERDAY.
YOU SAID YOU'RE LEAVING
GOVERNMENT TO PURSUE THE NEXT
PHASE OF YOUR CAREER.
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
>> WELL, KAITLAN, WHAT I WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE, AND I THINK IT
WILL BE, IS TO UTILIZE AS YOU
MENTIONED THE 54-YEAR EXPERIENCE
I HAVE AT THE NIH, INCLUDING 38
YEARS AS THE DIRECTOR OF NIAID
AND HAVING HAD THE PRIVILEGE AND
HONOR OF SERVING SEVEN
PRESIDENTS THROUGH SOME VERY
HISTORIC OUTBREAKS, DATING ALL
THE WAY BACK TO HIV, THAT I
MIGHT USE MY EXPERIENCE IN
SPEAKING, WRITING, LECTURING AND
INTERACTING WITH THE YOUNGER
GENERATION OF SCIENTISTS WHO
HOPEFULLY INSPIRE SCIENTISTS AND
WOULD BE SCIENTISTS AND
PHYSICIANS TO ENTER A CAREER OF
PUBLIC SERVICE, PARTICULARLY IN
THE ARENA OF PUBLIC HEALTH
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE.
AND IF I CAN DO THAT, I THINK I
MIGHT SOMEHOW AFTER MY ACTIVE
GOVERNMENT SERVICE PERHAPS
INSPIRE PEOPLE TO ENTER A FIELD
SIMILAR TO WHAT I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO AND WHAT I'VE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO DO OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES.
>> DR. FAUCI, WHAT IS YOUR
DEPARTURE TELL US ABOUT WHERE WE
ARE IN THE STATE OF THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, KAITLAN, I DON'T
THINK IT TELLS US ANYTHING
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHERE WE ARE, BUT
I CAN ADDRESS WHERE WE ARE, AND
I BELIEVE THAT WE'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE I HOPE AS THE
MONTHS GO BY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
GET THIS OUTBREAK DOWN TO A LOW
ENOUGH LEVEL SO THAT IT WON'T
DISRUPT SOCIETY TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT HAS OVER THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS.
WE HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO DO
IT, WE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT IT.
WE STILL AS I TOLD YOU SEVERAL
TIMES OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS, WE ONLY HAVE 67% OF OUR
POPULATION VACCINATED AND ONLY
ABOUT HALF OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
BOOSTED.
THAT IS REALLY UNACCEPTABLE WHEN
YOU COMPARE US TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD, INCLUDING LOWER AND
MIDDLE INCOME COUNTRIES.
SO WE GOT TO DO BETTER THAN
THAT.
THIS IS A FORMIDABLE VIRUS, NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO, THERE IS
GOING TO BE SUFFERING AND PAIN.
WE CAN ALLEVIATE IT A LOT BETTER
IF WE FOLLOW THE VERY OBVIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICES OF
VACCINATING AND BOOSTING AND
HOPEFULLY AS WE GET INTO THE
FALL, AND THE MORE UPDATED
BOOSTERS, PARTICULARLY THE NEW
BIVALENT BOOSTERS THAT BECOME
AVAILABLE IN SEPTEMBER, THAT WE
UTILIZE THEM.
>> AND I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
THIS, DR. FAUCI, REPUBLICANS
REALLY, TO YOU, TO THEM YOU ARE
A SYMBOL OF THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT CAME ALONG WITH COVID-19.
OF COURSE, REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
AND YOU HAVE CLASHED MANY TIMES
AND THEY ARE EXPECTED TO TAKE
OVER THE HOUSE THIS FALL,
POTENTIALLY, AND THEY PROMISED
TO INVESTIGATE YOU IF THEY DID.
DID THAT HAVE ANY ROLE IN YOUR
DEPARTURE?
>> NONE AT ALL, KAITLAN.
REALLY, NONE AT ALL.
NOT EVEN A SLIGHT AMOUNT.
I HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE.
AND I CAN DEFEND EVERYTHING I'VE
DONE.
SO THAT DOESN'T PHASE ME OR
BOTHER ME.
MY DECISIONS OF STEPPING DOWN GO
BACK WELL OVER A YEAR.
I HAD DECIDED I MIGHT WANT TO
STEP DOWN AT THE END OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, BUT WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS ELECTED, ONE
OF THE FIRST THINGS HE DID WAS
TO ASK ME TO JOIN AND BE HIS
CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER, WHICH I
TOOK AS A GREAT HONOR AND I
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ACCEPTED.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING TO LAST
ABOUT A YEAR THAT WE WOULD BE
HAVING COVID BEHIND US AFTER A
YEAR.
BUT OBVIOUSLY PAINFULLY SO,
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
BUT HAVING THOUGHT ABOUT THAT,
AND AS YOU SAID NOW, WITH A
PRIOR QUESTION A MOMENT AGO, I
THINK WE'RE IN A RELATIVELY GOOD
PLACE WITH REGARD TO COVID, IF
WE UTILIZE AND IMPLEMENT THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE HAVE, AND
I JUST FELT IT WAS THE RIGHT
TIME, PARTICULARLY SINCE I'M
STILL HEALTHY AND ENERGETIC AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT I WANT TO
DO, AND I THINK THAT'S THE TIME
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PHASE.
>> IF ONCE YOU RETIRED
REPUBLICANS WANT YOU TO GO
TESTIFY, IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
WOULD DO?
>> SURE, I CERTAINLY WOULD
CONSIDER THAT.
BUT YOU GOT TO REMEMBER, I
BELIEVE OVERSIGHT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE.
AND I WELCOME IT AND CAN BE
PRODUCTIVE.
BUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED UP UNTIL
NOW IS MORE OF A CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION THAN IT IS
OVERSIGHT.
SO, SURE, I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
COOPERATE, SO LONG AS WE MAKE IT
SOMETHING THAT SAY DIGNIFIED
OVERSIGHT, WHICH IT SHOULD BE.
AND NOT JUST BRINGING UP
RIDICULOUS THINGS AND ATTACKING
MY CHARACTER.
THAT'S NOT OVERSIGHT.
>> AS WE SAID AT THE BEGINNING,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE THIS CAREER
THAT IT DOESN'T MATCH A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
DIFFERENT CRISES YOU'VE
CONFRONTED, RIGHT NOW I KNOW
SANJAY WAS SAYING EARLIER ONE OF
YOUR BIGGEST CONCERNS 20 YEARS
AGO WAS WHAT WE SAW IN THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE BIGGEST
HEALTH THREAT NOW?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS TO GET
THROUGH THIS OUTBREAK THAT WE'RE
IN RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS HISTORIC, KAITLAN.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS IN WELL OVER 100 YEARS.
IT IS TO GET THROUGH THIS, AND
AT THE SAME TIME HAVE LESSONS
LEARNED THAT WOULD PREPARE US
FOR THE INEVITABILITY OF ANOTHER
OUTBREAK.
I'M SURE AS SANJAY TOLD YOU FOR
YEARS THAT HE AND I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS, I'VE BEEN
SAYING THAT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED, OF COURSE, PANDEMICS
WILL OCCUR.
AND THERE IS PREPARATION AND
THERE IS RESPONSE.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO DO BETTER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE LEARNED
IMPORTANT LESSONS THROUGH THIS
PAINFUL 2 1/2 YEAR EXPERIENCE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH.
>> AND WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
REFLECTING ON, IN THESE DAYS AS
YOU ARE NOW ANNOUNCING YOUR
DEPARTURE AND YOU ONLY HAVE A
FEW MONTHS LEFT IN THESE ROLES?
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN REFLECTING ON
FROM YOUR OWN EXPERIENCES?
>> WELL, MY EXPERIENCES GO BACK,
AS YOU KNOW, FOUR DECADES OF
LEADERSHIP AT NIAID.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME A LOT
NOW, I MEAN, THE IDEA OF MAKING
SURE WE GET YOUNGER GENERATIONS,
SMART, ENTHUSIASTIC PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE FIELD THAT I'M
INVOLVED IN, WHICH IS MEDICINE,
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH, I
JUST AM VERY DISTURBED BY THE
INTENSE DIVISIVENESS IN OUR
COUNTRY, AND IF EVER THERE WAS A
SITUATION WHERE WE WANTED
EVERYONE TO PULL TOGETHER, AND
RECOGNIZE WE'RE DEALING WITH
COMMON ENEMIES WHICH ARE THESE
PATHOGENS THAT CAUSE OUTBREAKS
AND HAVE ALREADY, WITH COVID,
KILLED 1 MILLION AMERICANS, THAT
IS NOT TIME TO HAVE POLITICAL
IDEATION BE SEPARATING US IN
WHAT SHOULD BE A COMMON EFFORT
TO END THIS.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
SO WHEN I REFLECT, I HOPE THINGS
IMPROVE, I'M FUNDAMENTALLY
CAUTIOUS, OPTIMIST, AND I OFTEN
SAY I LOOK FOR THE FACT THAT
HOPEFULLY THE BETTER ANGELS IN
ALL OF US WILL ULTIMATELY EMERGE
AND WE'LL BE A COUNTRY THAT
PULLS TOGETHER IN THE COMMON
ENEMY AS OPPOSED TO ONE THAT
SEEMS TO BE FIGHTING WITH EACH
OTHER.
>> DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, NO ONE CAN
DENY